en france on a des idées et on a aussi
des masques restaurer nos capacités de
production fut laborieux puisque l'une
des dernières usines de masques avait
fermé en 2018
nous étions donc dépendants des imports
étrangers d'où la pénurie subie en début
de pandémie
mais désormais la production française a
repris et conformément au souhait d'
emmanuel macron fin mars 2020 la france
a récupéré sa souveraineté avant la
crise nous produisions en france 3,3
millions de masques par semaine fin
avril nous serons à plus de 10 millions
nous aurons plus que triplé en quelques
semaines et nous continuerons cet effort
pour continuer la multiplication de nos
capacités de production et je veux que
d'ici la fin de l'année nous ayons
obtenu justement cette indépendance
pleine et entière des centaines
d'entreprises produisent désormais des
masques en france allant du géant du
luxe à la manufacture traditionnel en
passant par la start up et la capacité
de production multipliée par 30 en moins
d'un an a atteint les 100 millions de
masques sanitaires par semaine certaines
de ces sociétés sont aidées par l'état
et pour soutenir la filière l'initiative
savoir faire ensemble regroupe les
acteurs du textile mettre en place des
solutions pour faciliter les liens entre
donneurs d'ordre et fournisseurs booster
l'écosystème de la fabrication française
en favorisant les liens entre membres du
réseau
on peut crier cocorico mais il ya un hic
car étonnamment cela ne signifie pas que
la commande publique favorise les
masques fabriqués en france une enquête
de nos collègues de france info révèle
que les collectivités région département
se fournissent en masque parfois
produits en chine en tunisie en pologne
ou alors s'adresse à des entreprises
locales mais qui en réalité revendre des
protections fabriqués à des milliers de
kilomètres
[Musique]
des masques chinois s'invite au conseil
général du var des masques vietnamiens à
la métropole nice côte d'azur comment
est ce possible
plusieurs raisons expliquent cette
importation tu ne parles critère du prix
de l'autre les critères techniques
particuliers pouvant être exigée dans
l'appel d'offres et de plus les marchés
publics doivent se plier aux règles de
concurrence européennes obligatoire et
le pays de fabrication n'entre pas dans
les critères de sélection
ainsi la france retient d'une main ce
qu'elle se voit obligé de repousser de
l'autre une sorte de mascarade
mais qu'est ce donc que cette
souveraineté européenne celle là même
qui nous supprime la possibilité de
souveraineté nationale
une situation décrite comme
schizophrénique par les syndicats ou
fédérations du textile alors comment
opté pour la préférence nationale sans
se faire attaquer par les entreprises
étrangères pour non respect des règles
de concurrence en augmentant par exemple
le poids des critères sociaux et
environnementaux à l'appel d'offres et
la france pourrait devenir imbattable
son bilan carbone en bandoulière est
actuellement les discussions sont vives
le ministère de l'économie les acteurs
du secteur réfléchissent à un billet
pour valoriser les produits locaux
messieurs les commanditaires à vos
marques